first on CBS this morning investigators
tell 48 hours they now have a person of
interest in the mysterious death of
actress Natalie Wood in November 1981
the rebel without a cause actress
drowned after disappearing from her
family's yacht woods death was
originally ruled an accident but in 2011
the Los Angeles County Sheriff's
Department reopened that investigation
48 hours correspondent Erin Moriarty has
covered the wood case for six years in
this preview of Saturday's Saturday's 48
hours investigators reveal new leads in
this Hollywood mystery for the first
time in life Natalie Wood was one of the
biggest film stars imaginable a child
star in miracle on 34th Street then
rebel without a cause I'm never going
back and gypsy I am Gypsy Rose Lee but
it is her mysterious death that keeps
her legend alive in 1981 Natalie Wood
was out sailing with her husband actor
Robert Wagner her oscar-winning young
co-star Christopher Walken and their
captain Denis tavern when she
mysteriously disappeared from the yacht
I remember people coming on the boat
saying that they had found Natalie Wood
floating I just couldn't believe it
Natalie's death was quickly ruled an
accidental drowning but rumors and
allegations of foul play remained fueled
in great part by the boat's captain
Denis tavern he claims there was a
terrible fight between Natalie and
Wagner outside on the back of the boat
that night I believe that Robert Wagner
was with her up until the moment she
went into the water i'm lieutenant john
karina 30 years later in 2011 Davern and
over 700 others signed a petition asking
the los angeles county sheriff's
department for a second look this new
information is substantial enough for us
to make want to take another look at the
case the case was reopened
lieutenant Carina and veteran homicide
detective Ralph Hernandez have been
dogged ly working it ever since
so over the last six years have you been
able to get
even more evidence that makes you
question that this was an accident
we have we believed that there was a lot
more to it than what was being told they
weren't alone a medical examiner after
reviewing the number of bruises in the
autopsy report changed the manner of
death from accidental to undetermined
why are all these bruises suspicious to
you because she looked like the victim
of an assault and for the first time
investigators say they have
corroboration for Davern story about the
fight when the case was reopened two new
witnesses from a neighboring boat came
forward claiming they not only heard the
fight one says she saw it saw figures on
the back of the splendor male and a
female whose voices they recognized as
being Robert Wagner and Natalie Wood
arguing in the back of the boat
investigators still don't know how
Natalie Wood got in the water but
lieutenant Corina has his suspicions
do you believe Natalie Wood was murdered
I think it's suspicious enough to make
us think that something happened I don't
think she got in the water herself I
don't think she fell into the water and
they have questions about Robert
Wagner's accounts of that night do you
think Robert Wagner has ever told the
truth of exactly what happened I haven't
seen it and his version of events just
don't add up to the evidence and the
witnesses we found no when the case was
reopened
lieutenant Corina said Robert Wagner was
not a suspect we asked if that had
changed cuz we've investigated the case
over the last six years I think he's
more of a person of interest now we know
now that he was the last person to be
with Natalie before she disappeared
Robert Wagner declined 48-hours request
for an interview Erin Moriarty joins us
at the table to discuss Erin good
morning I remember this was such a huge
story at the time it was 24/7 coverage
because she was a big deal so help us
understand about Robert Wagner what's
the difference between a person of
interest and a suspect well he's never
been a suspect he is not now what it is
he's a person of interest they're
calling him at for the
very first time because they believe
this is a suspicious death and they now
believe on what they've gathered that he
was the last person to see her alive
they also say that his accounts over the
years just don't match the evidence that
they've gathered in the witnesses I
think the biggest example is that what I
meant mentioned in the piece is that
Wagner said they did not have a fight
before she disappeared and for a long
time it was just the ship's captain who
said it
now the investigators say they have two
new witnesses who claim that they heard
the fight and one actually said she saw
it also Wagner story has changed a
little bit over the years initially
there was broken glass from a wine
bottle in the salon he told
investigators it was broken in rough
seas later he admitted that he did break
it as part of a fight inside the salon
any reason what any any do you have any
answer as to why the witnesses are
coming forward now thirty years later
well I think because it was called an
accident according to the investigators
they thought it wouldn't help but why
one has credibility's but specifically
on Friday night one witness saw a fight
Friday night the night before and he
said it was actually Natalie being
Natalie Wood being the aggressor and she
fell on her knee and sure enough in the
autopsy in the autopsy report there's a
bruise on ur knees so they find these
new accounts acceptable and credible
very interesting thank you very much
Erin Moriarty you can see Erin's full
report it's called Natalie Wood death in
dark water on 48 hours Saturday night at
10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS